stained
can't drive through are you serious just
keep going
all right people we are live from the
swamp that's right we are in Washington
D.C I'm still Dave Rubin this is still
the Reuben report we are coming to you
an hour later than usual we flew in the
whole team we just got here about an
hour ago uh we were working on the show
on the plane and early this morning we
have put together a fine program for you
and we are here for three days uh that's
right over the course of the next three
days we have reached out to all sorts of
people in politics political people
Republicans Democrats Senators
congressmen
etc etc we got a whole bunch of
interviews that I'll be doing over the
course of the next three days from this
very studio uh we're also going to be
doing obviously the the normal live show
that we're doing right now and as an
interesting note I'm putting this out
into the universe right now because
maybe something good will come back if I
put this out we've reached out to about
I don't know about dozen Republicans
about a dozen Democrats every single
Republican that we reached out to
responded to us and responded positively
we're still in the process of scheduling
some of things only one Republican said
no but every other Republican said yes
and were working out all the details on
that we did not get one response from a
Democrat so it's not that they said no
they didn't even respond and we went
through all the proper channels so we
are trying you know I know one of the
big things right now is everyone's
fearing you know we just continue to go
off into our own worlds our own Echo
Chambers all that stuff and and these
paths that we seem to be on which in the
United States of America should be
something like this or at least a little
bit like this they're going like that
instead but we are trying I want to have
those conversations and and I want to be
clear if you are a representative for
ilhan Omar or AOC or Rashida talibur Joe
Biden or Kamala Harris or Elizabeth
Warren or any of these people Bernie
Sanders that we've reached out to uh yes
have I been rough on you guys
sure uh do I hide that no will I treat
you with absolute respect and conduct an
interview in the same manner uh with you
as I would with someone who I happen to
agree with more I absolutely would so
I'm here I got a chair I got another
chair I got a table we got coffee and
refreshments and if you are a Democrat
watching this or you are someone who
supports a Democrat uh maybe uh Pinger
Congressman or congresswoman or Senator
and see if we can get some some of them
in here but in the meantime we're going
to get to a normal regular Reuben report
show again live from the swamp and
basically what we're going to be doing
today is talking about that blueprint
that we've been talking about for a
while right Ron DeSantis in Florida
obviously sort of has this blueprint not
sort of actually has this blueprint for
America there is a way to do this thing
right and it does not come top down it
comes bottom up it starts at the states
and you can see it it's happening right
now it is being replicated Across the
Nation right now it's quite beautiful
there are a whole bunch of winds to see
and then we'll get into some general
political fighting and uh much more so
here we go with the Big Show uh first
off uh one of the reasons that we're
here this week is because Congress is in
session so basically everybody's here
that's why we came here because we were
like look we don't want to just come on
and off week when you never know who's
in DC everyone's here one of the things
that Congress is voting on right now
over the last couple days is the
Republicans presented a parental rights
in education Bill and
it really is modeled off of what Ron
DeSantis has been doing for the last
year in Florida that basically we
shouldn't have state employees teachers
talking to kids about sex that you
shouldn't be talking about gender Theory
with kids who aren't old enough to
understand it that there should be
transparency in education that remember
when you went to the zoo with school in
fourth grade you had to have a parental
slip your parents had to sign something
or you couldn't go that there should
just be more transparency and as I often
say the Democrats seem to love
everything trans except transparency so
they're freaking out about this bill
because they apparently want teachers to
be able to give kids other names and
hide it from the parents and a bunch of
other weird stuff encourage them to chop
off genitals Etc so here's AOC on the
floor of Congress freaking out about
parental rights in education and yes she
uses the f word
relational Solutions the American
Library Association coming out against
this Republican proposal
when we talk about Progressive values I
can say what my Progressive value is and
that is freedom over fascism thank you
gentlemen this time has expired the
gentleman from
oh Lord AOC I can't believe I'm in the
same vicinity like we're within a mile
of each other right now but again if you
come into this room I promise you I
really do mean it I would treat you with
respect but this new line that the
Democrats are using over and over you
can see the way the machine always
changes the truth right I always tell
you truth it's a Time release pill and
then the the machine always has a way of
sort of manipulating it this new line
that Democrats are using they brought
the culture wars in meaning that somehow
it's the Republicans because they're
pushing back against wokism are the ones
who started this thing uh actually
nobody was for any of this stuff these
bills wouldn't have been necessary if it
wasn't for the last decade of you guys
sexualizing children of you guys pushing
neo-racism and anti-anti-racism which is
actually racism on kids and the Litany
of other things that you were possible
are that you guys are constantly doing
right I mean this is we know they do
this so somehow if you push against it
then that's the real instigator of the
culture War actually it's just putting a
door with a lock on it and saying how
about no more of that but they lie about
everything you know they lie about
everything and and truly although I
would treat AOC with respect I would
play that clip I'll play this AOC you're
in town I'll go to the Capitol later and
wander around maybe we'll see you but I
would play her that clip and say do you
know the definition of fascism because
she seems to think that uh well first
off the fact that she even says the word
Freedom that the word Freedom can come
out of her mouth is crazy because she
doesn't believe in Freedom she believes
in state-sponsored power but here she is
saying she believes in Freedom over
fascism I don't think she knows what
fascism is fascism certainly is not
parents having a little bit of insight
into what their kids are learning what
state employees are teaching their kids
transparency I thought that would be a
progressive value but seemingly secrecy
seems to be a progressive value but
speaking of progressive values another
Progressive value of the day is outright
lying about everything here's Democrat
leader Hakeem Jeffries saying
Republicans don't want kids to learn
about the Holocaust stream Mega
Republicans don't want the Children of
America to learn about
the Holocaust
no like not true that's not in any bill
it's being taught in every single state
in America Most states have laws
requiring that the Holocaust be taught
but this is what they do they try to
scare the hell out of you about
everything absolutely everything so we
thought
I said Phoenix can we actually tell the
people what's in this parental rights
and education Bill we've already been
through this with
hb1557 in Florida which they call don't
say gay even though the word gay wasn't
in it but I thought okay this is a bill
that could be going Nationwide could we
get some facts on that and he said yes
yes we can so we've got some info from
the daily wire the House of
Representatives in a virtually straight
party line vote passed the parents Bill
of Rights uh the parent sorry the
parents Bill of Rights bill on Friday
Democrats unanimously oppose the measure
they were joined by five Republicans the
bill states that parents should have the
right to review and make copies of at no
cost the curriculum of their child's
school which should be publicly
available the right to a list of books
and other reading materials available in
the library of their child's School the
right to inspect such books or other
reading materials and the right to to
know if a School employee or contractor
acts to change a minor child's gender
markers pronouns or preferred name or
allow a child to change the child's
sex-based accommodations including
locker rooms or bathrooms you guys
really need to understand this
they are the ones that fear transparency
the bill is just so that you as a parent
would know what your kid is learning you
know anyone that's been to college you
get a syllabus at the beginning of the
year right and in that syllabus it says
here's what we're going to learn over
the course of the next six months here
is the reading material here's the these
days the information maybe you're gonna
have to download or an app you're gonna
have to download here's what we're going
to be doing in this class they don't
hide that's college level they don't
hide that information and only parse it
out throughout the year in weird ways we
are talking about state employees with
kids that are four five six seven eight
years old and now they're pushing this
into high school and we can have an
honest debate about when or if sex and
gender and all those things should be
taught in high schools and who that
should be left up to and everything else
that's a separate debate here but the
simple absolutely simple truth is every
single Democrat just voted against the
parents of America that means that they
think
that superintendents and school boards
and people who have nothing to do with
these kids other than in many cases just
there to indoctrinate them I mean you've
seen all these videos of teachers that
are that are outright saying they are
trying to indoctrinate these kids and
and change their thought processes away
from what their parents might want uh
they fear that they fear that the
parents might know what's going on so
every Democrat voted against this thing
and five Republicans I'd love to get the
name of those five Republicans uh so
look this will be you know how it works
the what's the mainstream media going to
do the Republicans were trying to pass
some evil bill that had something to do
with being mean to gay people and not
teaching the Holocaust and everything
else but it simply had nothing to do
with that but we do a rinse uh repeat
cycle with the uh with the lies that the
Democrats put out there but on the pot
on the positive note
the Republicans are in charge of the
house right now what have I been saying
for a while I sense the Republicans are
starting to show teeth they are starting
to say we will not just go on this end
this endless descent to hell with you
guys we're going to pass some bills that
make sense and here's Kevin McCarthy New
House Majority Leader I'm going to be
interviewing him tomorrow at the Capitol
in front of a live audience uh
celebrating the passage of the parental
rights bill you now have a say in your
kids education you get the warning
there's any violence on the campus you
get to know where the money is being
spent you need to get to know what the
reading materials are and you get to
protect your children's privacy as well
I just want to thank Julia letlow
chairwoman Fox for their work on this
and for all the members for helping
putting this across the line and for the
American public to trust us with the
majority and we're keeping our promise
to you our commitment to America the
parents will have a say in their kids
education
the parents will have a say in their
kids education look guys we can have an
honest debate I know we can do it I know
most people can we can have an honest
debate about what role the government
should have in education you know what's
blowing up right now is more and more
homeschooling pods people that are just
taking their kids out of the system all
together because people have just had it
with this nonsense right you send your
kid to school let's forget
five-year-olds let's say fourth grade so
fourth grade what are you about 11 years
old something like that 10 years old
like you're not you're not just a child
child you're certainly a child at that
age but what what do you want a fourth
grader to learn you might want them to
learn math and and division you might
want them to learn the beginnings of
History like a little bit of that stuff
but what just think about it putting
aside your feelings about trans stuff or
anything else what what is the role of
Education in your child's life and
especially if that's going to be State
education so I don't think it has
anything to do with teaching your child
about pronouns pounds or trying to teach
your child that they are racist because
of the color of their skin or that kid
over there has more worth and should get
a job more easily this is a complete
undoing of everything that is American
and the Republicans are standing up
against it and the Democrats are all in
on it it's not only that they're all in
on it they're lying about it Hakeem
Jeffries saying we're not going to teach
about the Holocaust and AOC calling it
fascism it's just extraordinary but
they're going to keep doing that and you
know why they're going to keep doing
that because they don't have truth
behind them and the Republicans are
starting to rack up wins this is good I
know guys a lot of shows go by
and even though I try to end them on
that that sort of white pill that silver
lining it's like there are winds
happening that I don't have to wait to
the end of the show to get to today
Kevin McCarthy tweeted this out winds
are happening right now House
Republicans are keeping our commitment
and changing Congress and he listed out
some of the things that they've done
they've repealed the 87 000 IRS agents
allowed for open amendments nullified
DC's soft on crime law and did proxy
voting for Congress pass the parents
Bill of Rights created a China select
committee so they are doing the stuff we
asked parents rights good getting rid of
these 87 000 IRS agents the government
that prints money relentlessly is always
looking for more of your money getting
rid of them looking into China like good
things are happening but the question is
why why is it happening now finally and
how are they actually doing it and dare
I say
while I sit here in DC not in the sunny
lovely free state of Florida that it has
something to do with that Florida
blueprint we've been doing it so right
in Florida and I say we as a as a
Floridian now but Florida was doing it
right even before me which is why I
moved there uh that now it is being
blueprinted across the country so let's
go back uh to a little bit of how that
blueprint came to be you may remember
this speech we played a little bit of
this a while back this is Ron DeSantis
on inauguration day about two months ago
plainly laying out what that Florida
blueprint for freedom is
Law and Order we have protected the
rights of parents we have respected our
taxpayers and we reject woke ideology
we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight the woke in the schools we fight
the woken the corporations we will never
ever surrender to the woke mob Florida
is where woke goes to die
you get chills up the spine Florida is
where woke goes to die well it gets
stupider it really does because not only
do they lie about everything but then
these ridiculous organizations like the
NAACP which used to be good right they
were good organizations that were out
there that were fighting for True
equality and that were fighting for free
speech and American values but they
become all of these organizations they
become patently Lefty Progressive whack
job uh non-profits so the NAACP you are
not going to believe this one if you
have not heard about it they have issued
a warning to black people not to visit
Florida yes that's right and a reporter
asked the governor about it over the
weekend yes one more uh Governor the
four
he voted yesterday to ask the National
Branch to issue travel advisory for
black
Americans you know advising them not to
come into Florida over the AP
African-American history controversy
what a joke
what a joke yeah we'll see how we'll see
how effective that is you know just
remember
during covid these people would be on
CNN all this stuff Slam in Florida
saying we were so bad don't go to
Florida and then they would end up being
spotted on the beach somewhere
vacationing in Florida so this is just
ridiculous I mean
okay yes you guys get it's patently
ridiculous I should note that I had
lunch with a black friend in Miami on
Saturday we both had grouper sandwiches
actually it sounds like a joke a black
guy and a gay guy walk into a restaurant
in Florida nobody attacked us it was no
we didn't get banned or bunched DeSantis
didn't send out his goons black guy
don't talk about racism gay guy don't
get married it's all so stupid but the
media loves the nonsense and now let me
prove how the media loves the nonsense
what's one of the things I say to you
guys all the time the media laanders the
lies and and one of the ways they
launder the lies is they they accept
Democrat and leftist framing of
everything so as you know
hb1557 in Florida was a parental rights
and education bill just so you would
have a sense of what's going on you send
your kid as a new father you know I've
got now Justin's almost eight Luke's
almost six months now eight months and
six months it's like you're these are
these little precious creatures when I
can only imagine what it'll be like one
day when I put them on that bus or drop
them off or whatever it might be uh
where in Florida I'll probably be able
to send them to a to a public school
because Florida is doing it right but
the idea of okay at 7am I'm putting them
on this bus and now I don't see them
until 3 P.M these people are caretakers
for your children they are not supposed
to be be inflicting Insanity on their
minds but that's what we've allowed and
listen to how they frame this you guys
know the word gay was not in this there
was nothing about don't say gay they are
not stopping gay parents from sending
their kid to school it has nothing about
not respecting anyone it mostly was
about making sure that parents would
know what's going on but the Democrats
and the and the mainstream media they
control the narrative together so here's
ABC's Martha raddatz she's considered a
reputable journalist but note she
doesn't say hb155 seven or talk about
parental rights in education or
transparency in education she calls it
don't say gay and she tries to link it
to scary Ron DeSantis 2024. DeSantis
Florida here he announced an expansion
of the controversial uh lock don't say
gay to all grades now is somebody going
to help him this is a this is a five he
is intentionally picking we have seen
him use the governor's office for these
kind of set plays to be able to pick and
choose a a slice of a republican culture
war that he wants to see the friendly
media that he wants to get on Fox News
and that's how he's raised his profile
away from those other Challengers but it
has also got him into trouble
oh man you see what I mean about rinse
and repeat guys first off she doesn't
she uses the don't say gay name of it
right she doesn't explain what it is and
then the the guy that's talking there
it's the Republican culture War it's
exactly what AOC did before it's always
the Republicans because they're pushing
back Republicans pounce they're always
pouncing these people it's just so
nonsensical but it continues mainstream
media and the other thing mainstream
media does when they're laundering the
lies they take disgraced people so Donna
Brazil you remember Donna Brazil she was
the head of the Democrat National
Convention uh she didn't do very well
there so then she became a CNN
correspondent uh and then as a CNN
correspondent she actually gave one of
the presidential debate questions to
Hillary Clinton which was not allowed so
she had to resign in disgrace then she
became a Fox News correspondent after
that well here she's back she just comes
back like Freddy Krueger you got to bury
the bones she's back and yeah she's also
trying to scare the hell out of you over
Ron DeSantis because apparently she
wants her children to be taught about
racism and chomping genitals off
videotape but Ron DeSantis is running on
a 1950s America not a 2050 America
America the future so I think Joe Biden
will have a real good Advantage going
into the 2024. now I should
Joe Biden will not have an advantage
well I understand you guys will do
everything possible to give him an
advantage but he won't even know what
year it is in 2024. Ron DeSantis look
you know it's funny when we were going
through this clip I was thinking does
Rhonda Sanders want to take us back to
1950s America what does that mean
well
first off the way she's framing it of
course that's not what he wants to take
him take America back to the way she's
framing it the implication is when
America was truly racist and homophobic
and blah blah blah but in another
framing of that you could say maybe we
should go a little bit backwards we're
always going forwards progressives are
always taking us forward but progress
for the sake of progress isn't good
progress for the sake of equality is
good but you don't want to always just
progress no matter what sometimes you're
progressing and you're going real fast
and you're progressing and then you
realize oh the road ends and it goes off
a cliff that's basically what they're
trying to do to us right now I would say
that in 1950s America for the flaws that
we had and we certainly had things that
we needed to take care of and Civil
Rights Act and a whole bunch of other
things and we did get more equality over
the years and marriage equality and
things of that nature but we weren't
suffering from this Mass delusion of
lunacy that boys or girls and girls or
boys and it was not being taught in
mainstream America that racism was okay
even really even in the 50s maybe in
some places in the South but it was it
was not part of the culture and again we
fought a war fairly close to our
founding to end slavery but these these
hucksters and grifters it never ends but
now there's another piece of this that's
really interesting so the mainstream
media is attacking DeSantis relentlessly
and now Donald Trump is back attacking
DeSantis direct relentlessly so who do
you think the real threat is notice if
you watched any of the Sunday shows and
I hope you didn't we try to recap them
here for you so that you can get out
there on a Sunday and maybe go to this
farmer's market and watch your kid play
soccer but
the all of the Sunday shows they were
all focused on DeSantis and last week
remember Trump relentlessly going after
DeSantis a New York attorney general is
going or a New York D.A district
attorney is going after Trump saying
he's going to put him in jail which of
course didn't happen and the Trump's
whole attack was on DeSantis well now
you've got mainstream media going after
DeSantis lying about the bills and all
of that stuff and now Trump uh over the
weekend gave his first big rally in a
while he was in Waco Texas which is
certainly Trump country that is red red
red red meat uh Trump area he went to
Texas and he was given a speech and he
went after DeSantis but it kind of fell
flat with the audience listen to that
you can basically hear a pin drop here
and I don't think he was getting the
response he wanted long before this guy
became governor Florida was tremendously
successful under Rick Scott
he was look whether you like him or not
Charlie Christ it was very successful he
was a republican at the time
but Florida's been successful for
decades in fact probably as or more
successful than it is now
yeah
Donald I like you I voted for you we'll
do a sit down again and discuss this
stuff but no Florida is way more
successful now than ever it certainly is
more red than ever 20-point win for
DeSantis super majority for the
Republicans on both sides 1200 people
moving in a day massive infrastructure
projects being moved up 20-year projects
that are now happening in seven years
because of the influx of people all-time
low crime all-time low unemployment like
it's it's happening here you don't have
to lie to do this there is a case to be
made for you Donald Trump but you could
feel it in that crowd they don't like it
either they yes they love Trump they
love Trump will these people go to the
ends of Earth for Trump probably will
they vote for Trump no matter what
probably but you can feel it there the
the TR I think what Trump is is not
understanding right now is there is a
path for you there's certainly a path
for him he has the base of the base that
may be all you need to win in a primary
but to try to take out the guy who not
only is the best governor in the United
States but then could kind of lie like
oh it was always so great in Florida
Florida was red then it was blue then it
was purple then it was blue again then
it was red like it's happening in
Florida Florida was the joke of America
for most of my life like that's where
people old people go to die that was
that was it right Del Boca Vista and now
Florida is the entire Tech sector moved
from Silicon Valley to Miami like there
is something so incredible happening
there and
it's like people are not buying that I
think that's a real mistake and the
thing is when when you're lying about it
and they know you're lying it's like we
can just very easily find video of you
saying how great Florida is here's Trump
in 2020 while in Erie Pennsylvania
saying that Pennsylvania should be more
like you're not going to believe it yeah
Florida even open yet
the hell is going on with your state
you know Florida's open all these
Florida had a surge great Governor surge
went down
yeah that's true and guess who was the
governor at the time it was Ron DeSantis
he's saying what the hell's going on up
here Pennsylvania you should be more
like Florida you got a great Governor
down there a governor that he endorsed
two times including just a couple months
ago and now he's making up all these
nonsensical well the silly nicknames
like none of it's working but so now
you've got the mainstream media right
corporate press ABC CBS MSNBC all of
that going in on DeSantis you've got
Trump who is only focused on DeSantis
what I'm trying to show you here is when
they're when everyone's going after
somebody maybe that's the guy that they
fear right nobody's going after Trump
anymore that's just reality okay uh but
it's not just that this was a really
really weird moment on Fox News so for
those of you that think Fox News is in
the tank for DeSantis and trying to take
out uh uh Donald Trump listen to this
moment so here's a guy his name's Mark
Simone he's a radio host he completely
makes up what he's about to say here I
want you to listen to what he's saying
he's asked about who's running
desantis's campaign listen to the way he
says it the actual full words that are
coming out of his mouth the way he's
laughing as he says it and it's none of
it's definitive I've already painted
this too much for you but just take a
look he's not great as far as campaign
skills he may get there but he doesn't
have them yet uh and I was Ron in his
campaign the bushes are all tangled up
with him uh Bush that can raise him a
billion dollars and give him all kinds
of money Jeb Bush George Bush yeah
Karl Rove is involved I assume he'll be
the coach on the field I think he is but
do you know that he's been advising the
sound
uh did you catch any of that like he
just made it up he didn't say any of
those who who's running at the bushes
the Jeb Bush
there there is literally no evidence if
evidence comes out at some point that
George W Bush and Jeb Bush are running
the campaign yeah Jeb Bush was governor
of Florida uh Jeb Bush was at the
inauguration uh and I suspect they're
friendly to some extent and that's okay
also Ronda said this hasn't even
freaking declared so this guy pretending
that he knows who's running the campaign
which would be illegal uh against
Florida law like it's just completely
nonsense and then Carl Yeah Carl Road
like they just say things the that guy
should not be allowed he should someone
at Fox
an executive at Fox should say did you
just make that up did do you know for a
fact that the bushes and Karl Rove are
running his campaign that he has not
announced yet and if the answer is no he
should never be allowed on Fox again so
you know I go on Fox a lot but like none
of this none of this whether it's people
or networks is above uh criticism but
the other thing that's been happening
over the last couple days and you really
saw this after the the D.A in New York
Alvin Bragg went after Trump so he's
going after DeSantis relentlessly going
after this Addison it's like man
shouldn't you be focused on the D.A
that's trying to take you to jail which
of course did not happen right it was
supposed to happen last Tuesday it did
not happen at all and it's and it's just
not going to happen I I I suppose at
this point there's still some tiny
chance but it does not look like it's
gonna happen and again it should not
happen and it's a total uh farce and all
of that stuff but as Trump was aiming
all of his fire at DeSantis the new
thing that he keeps saying is that
DeSantis is a rhino and a global now
first off if a rhino and a globalist is
a guy who opens up the state who keeps
taxes low who gets wokism out of school
who's fighting ESG with 19 other states
and doing all of the things right that
the scientist is doing then I think
we're all rhinos and globalists now I
have a whole other it's usually Media
Matters that Clips me out of context but
that's going to be the the Maga people
um he's doing everything right here
everyone knows it but Trump is also
trying to pin him on the Karl roves and
the Paul Ryan's and the George soroses
because you know there's nothing like
Karl Roven Paul Ryan and George Soros
like you got to put a freaking crazy
puzzle together but everyone has Twitter
and over the weekend a bunch of tweets
came out you might find this one
interesting from Trump in June of 2016.
so great to have the endorsement and
support of Paul Ryan we will both be
working very hard to make America great
again and then of course in April of
2018 speaker Paul Ryan is a truly good
man and while he will not be seeking
re-election he will leave a legacy of
achievement that nobody can question we
are with you Paul so this is once again
somebody that Trump used to say all
these great things about is now number
one enemy and we're trying to pin him
somehow onto DeSantis
and it's like come on this stuff doesn't
work again Donnie make the case for
yourself make an honest case for
yourself without name calling say I am I
am more suited to the job I am up to the
job in a way that Ron DeSantis is not
you could say he's been a damn good
Governor but he doesn't have the full
skill set the full array of things that
you need to be president I did it once I
believe they stole it from me the second
time I'll do it again like make your
case but if your case is oh yeah Florida
was great before this guy he doesn't
know what he's doing he's he's a swamp
creature because he's in it with Karl
Urban Paul Ryan
I just don't think that's the case guys
I I are my feelings on this clear but
the point is we all share an enemy right
like Trump this is the other reason that
the fighting is unnecessary and why I
think DeSantis whether he's running or
not is doing a nice job by mostly
ignoring it Trump is not the enemy
DeSantis is not the enemy if you love
freedom okay if you love freedom and you
love America and you love transparency
as opposed to
transsexuality which I actually don't
have a problem with if you're an adult
but then okay fine
uh we share an enemy guys and the enemy
is the swamp right the enemy I'm in DC
right now the enemy is the ever existing
political state that regardless of who
gets into power it seems to always grow
and always want more and never do
anything for us but will protect borders
halfway across the world and all of
these things so you know what I'm here
to do over the next couple days I am
here to ask every single politician that
I sit down with and again only
Republicans have agreed to do it what
are you going to do to fix DC what are
you going to do to shut down the people
that always want more that just want
more and it has very little to do with
anyone's mate anyone's life being made
better one of those people would be a
former Massachusetts senator former
presidential candidate former Secretary
of State John Kerry John Kerry who also
as you know married into big ketchup
money he married Teresa Hines so he's a
finds Kerry he's got all the ketchup
cash and there's a lot and it also put a
lot of high fructose corn syrup into
everyone's diet but okay fine uh here's
John Kerry saying that the Biden
Administration has way more stuff to do
when it comes to climate and he's going
to do it by executive action he doesn't
care he must stop the wind from blowing
well we're doing a lot more than just
the IRA
the IRA is a package that in and of
itself could get the 40 percent but in
addition to that the president is
issuing executive orders they'll be
changes on automobile on Light Truck
heavy truck heavy duty a number of
initiatives that are being taken by
State sub-national uh cities they really
kept us in the game frankly during the
Trump Administration when he pulled out
of the agreement but we've 75 percent of
the new electricity of the that came
online during the Trump Administration
came from renewable resources so we have
a lot of other options tools if you will
in the toolkit besides the IRA
I think he accidentally paid Trump a
compliment there we pulled out of the
Paris climate Accords and yet 75 percent
of our new energy was coming from
Renewables that seems a little bit odd
considering you call him orange Hitler
but do you see uh to link this to
something earlier AOC was talking about
fascism right and fascism you guys know
this AOC doesn't but I would try to
explain it to her if she'll sit down
with me here fascism is when
corporations and the government are
working together against you the
individual that's kind of the simplest
version of what fascism is Right fascism
is exactly what John Kerry is trying to
push in alongside Joe Biden they want to
get Industries they want to use the
pressure of the government to get
Industries to do exactly what they want
when it comes to Automobiles and light
truck and then he said cities I don't
know what are we going to be doing in
cities they will regulate the high hell
out of everything and by the way it's
not even in the president's jurisdiction
to do this stuff that's why they're
doing it all by executive action and
this is seems to be the way we get
governed now the president comes in he
signs a whole bunch of things the next
president comes in he reverses those
things the next guy comes in he does
them all over again and rinse and
repeating over and over and over and
over uh the uh the questioner the
interviewer also asked John Kerry about
Davos and the private jets and all the
fancy meat that they eat and all that
stuff and here's just general gobbley
by John Kerry private Aviation is
is an example of something where people
are starting to pay more attention and
um but when uh you know people who go to
Davos to talk about climate change fly
private it seems like they don't want to
make uh they actually I've talked to
them about it they offset they buy
offsets they offset and they are working
harder than most people I know to be
able to try to affect this transition
right oh that is horse you
horse-faced buffoon he looks like a
horse doesn't he something he I always
say he looks like a tree who are the
trees in uh Lord of the Rings again and
is the name of a tree or it was they
were all trees it's the type of species
thank you this is Connor's nail in it
today in a new studio he doesn't forget
any of his Lord of the Rings references
he looks like an IT the man is becoming
a tree he's so into green stuff he's
actually becoming a tree but he also
looks a little bit like a horse but
putting all that aside uh carbon
officers this is exactly the same stuff
that Bill Gates does Bill Gates buys all
the Farmland doesn't want you to eat
meat they don't want you to fly on a
plane they fly on airplanes if you think
for one second that John Kerry or
Leonardo DiCaprio or Bill Gates or any
of these people will ever give up their
luxuries you are crazy they will never
give them up and not only that and I've
been around some pretty wealthy people
you have no idea the level of wealth
that these have these people have in the
things they can get away with and if you
think that that Bill Gates during covet
he had all of his servants masked up I'm
sure while he lived however he wanted it
is four it is just a way of controlling
you we have carbon officers they pay
their my anyway
um another thing that's going on right
now speaking of uh strange governmental
Authority is there's been some
Congressional hearings on Tick Tock now
we have known for I would say at least
two years it has been basically known by
pretty much everyone in government that
tick talk is a Chinese spy app when you
download Tick Tock onto your phone
they've got access to all of your stuff
okay we've known this forever and yet
for some reason we allow it it's a
little bizarre I do not have the tick
tock on my phone well the CEO of tick
tock was testifying in front of Congress
over the last couple days and this is a
pretty great there's a lot of great
moments here but this is a pretty great
one he actually won't even say if the
Chinese government has anything to do
with any of this can you guarantee that
no one at bite dance had a role in
preparing you for today's hearing like I
said Congressman this is a high profile
hearing a lot of people around the world
were sending me wishes and unsolicited
advice but I prepared for this hearing
my team here in DC
yeah so he prepared for it it has
nothing to do with the government or the
government spyware which we know is on
there etc etc it just doesn't end now
it's interesting what's going on with
Tick Tock because there do seem to be
Republicans and Democrats that want to
get rid of tick tock now one theory that
I'm hearing lately I hadn't really
thought about this but a few people have
said it I think Elon Musk even
sub-tweeted someone on this is that one
of the reasons that the government that
we're getting Republicans and Democrats
to agree on something when they never
agree on anything is that right now if
you remove tick tock from the equation
the government basically has Facebook
the government has YouTube the
government has Snapchat Etc et cetera
the government doesn't have Twitter
anymore at least to the degree it did
because Elon has taken over but Tick
Tock as Chinese spyware gets all of our
data to China meaning the US government
is cut out of the equation here and
that's what the government's not happy
about that's why Democrats and
Republicans are pissed about it if the
U.S government was in kahootsi or with
China they'd be thrilled that they were
just getting more information off
everybody but since we started with AOC
we're also going to uh be ending the
show with ALC I got a couple more things
for you but watch this one this is just
this is just great AOC is very concerned
about losing Tick Tock she tick tocks a
lot so you have a congresswoman a
sitting congresswoman who's using
Chinese spyware on her phone do you
think there's an issue there and here
she very thoughtfully as AOC often does
explains why she doesn't want Tick-Tock
to be banned so why would we be
proposing a ban regarding such a
significant issue without being clued in
on this at all it just doesn't feel
right to me and additionally this case
needs to be made to the public we are a
government by the people and for the
people and if we want to make a decision
as significant as Banning Tick-Tock and
we believe or someone believes that
there's really important information
that the public deserves to know about
why such a decision will be justified
that information should be shared with
the public
yeah lady I get you feel that it
shouldn't but this is what we're doing
we're exposing the spying these people
are
what did we all do spiritually to end up
in a world with them how did we all end
up here with these people uh here's AOC
doing a commercial for Rupaul's Drag
Race it's only 10 seconds and I don't
even know exactly why we threw it into
Today's show but it just felt right
Join the Revolution I'm Alexandria
ocasio-cortez and I pledge allegiance to
the draft
I'm Alexandria ocasio-cortez said I
pledge allegiance to the drag ugh gross
all right we'll end you strong though
guys here from DC we didn't want to end
you didn't think we were going to end
you with AOC of course not uh actually
we thought we'd end you with this Trump
and DeSantis situation because I just
want to be clear again right now what
the Republicans have is a good crop of
people I'm a little frustrated with
Trump's Behavior I am obviously I voted
for the guy might vote for him again
obviously my thoughts on DeSantis and
his competency and Clarity and vision
are clear I really like vivec actually I
think today they are releasing vivec has
a new podcast out I'm his first guest
and we debate everything and we disagree
on a whole bunch of stuff tactics policy
a bunch more we agree on a lot too but
hopefully they get that out today I like
Nikki Haley had her on the show last
week
and whether you like these people or
don't like these people so far what
we've got are people that have resumes
that it is worth them being involved
right that's the thing Trump there's a
resume there right DeSantis here's what
I've done Nikki Haley former South
Carolina governor former U.S ambassador
to the U.N Vivek major VC guy has raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
understands economics this is a good
crop of people but the question is how
will it all shake out and will will
there be mutually assured destruction
I'm going to do my damnedest to make
sure that there isn't but I am going to
call out the bad actions when when I see
them I I I'm going to do my best to do
that uh here is uh Governor DeSantis
being asked if he would be VP in a trump
Administration would you be willing to
serve as vice president with Donald
Trump
I think I'm probably
um you know more of a of an executive
guy I mean I think that you want to be
able to do things that's part of the
reason I got in I got into this job is
because we we have action we're able to
make things happen and I think that's
probably what I'm best suited for
I think that's probably true and
wherever you fall on this Trump DeSantis
divide if if you have a strong feeling
about it one way or another I think it's
pretty clear you know I see a lot of
people being like why don't they just
join forces and and just take the ticket
together and basically forget the
primaries just like that's the winning
ticket blah blah I just don't see how
that could happen unfortunately and
that's also why why it was really
unfortunate that Trump went so all in on
you know the this you know implying that
he cheats on his wife and he might be
gay and that he's a rhino and a Glo like
all of this stuff it's like come on I'm
pretending that he hasn't done great
things in Florida make your case man
make your case that's my case to you
Donald J Trump on that note guys we got
a whole bunch of interviews today
tomorrow we are going to be at the
Capitol I am doing a live show with
Kevin McCarthy at the Capitol uh we have
about a hundred members of the locals
community that will be joining us for
that live interview and they're going to
ask some questions themselves and then
we're we're taking tours of the capital
and I'm going to jump on everybody's
tour and we'll wander around the capitol
going to be great I'm going to wander
around the mall a little bit tomorrow
night we've got to meet up here in DC
with our locals Community which if you
want to join us for that you can go to
Ruben report.locals.com and and for
subscribers only we'll release the
location on that one if you want to have
a drink hang out see what's what my full
interview with Nikki Haley who you're
just talking about is up right now
across platforms we leave you with the
cold clothes and then we do have a post
game show I am confirmed that we do have
a post game show from DC and about 32
seconds adios
and direction of the Department of
Injustice in Washington D.C
was investigating me for something that
is not a crime not a misdemeanor not an
affair
I never liked horse face I never liked
it I know it's just not it's terrible
thing
that wouldn't be the one
there is no one we have a great first
lady
[Music]
foreign
thank you